the Joe Rogan experience as someone
who's been listening to your podcast for
a long time actually that's something
that's uh I what you just said is
something that I have noticed a change
in actually over the years you know
going back and listening to some some of
the older ones where I think you were a
lot more how would I put it not
aggressive but a lot less tolerant of
say like religion and religious
viewpoints yeah you'll charge yeah yeah
and I think more recent you know more
recently over the years it's been like
okay I can I can get where that's coming
from and and what the value is and
whatnot well I can see a great benefit
from this podcast yeah I know other
people benefit from it but I've
experienced a great benefit in that I've
been exposed to a lot of different
points of view different personalities
different intellects and different
brilliant human beings that have very
different ideologies and I've met
brilliant people that I love and respect
that have polar opposite ideas on how
the world works yeah on both sides
I mean it's and through that I've
developed a sort of an understanding of
the various mechanisms that are at play
with why people believe what they
believe and how they benefit from
believing that and what's the pros and
cons and then I've just sort of opened
my mind up much more to various
viewpoints financial viewpoints
political viewpoints and I've developed
a much greater appreciation for the
variety of opinions and ideas yeah yeah
yeah no this baby has been awesome to
see like I've noticed it myself and been
like ah that's that's cool I realized
how dumb I am about I mean if I had
lived my life like I'm being honest if I
had lived my life without doing this
podcast I would probably be a far more
ignorant person right now in the same
place I feel like I've gotten not just
great conversations and met great people
at yourself and had a great time but
also I've been very privileged to have a
tremendous education
through all these people and for for
many of their books and and right after
you right now and the other grass
Tyson's coming on that's all so I'm
[ __ ] pumped meet him in the green
room oh yeah awesome so it's like having
these incredible people to share their
knowledge and a lifetime of learning you
know they can fill in blanks and educate
you and point you in the right direction
and also you can see the way their mind
works and then there's guys like you
know like David Goggins oh yeah who just
you realize like oh okay there's levels
to every this [ __ ] dude you know he
will he will make you realize that you
have more in the tank you know he will
make you realize you can do more you can
push more he [ __ ] sends me text
messages all the time like he's sent in
one yesterday and they just come out of
the blue and like there's no rhyme or
reason there's nothing going on no need
to respond hope all's well brother
continue to live in the grip of life as
you know nothing gets done by being a
[ __ ] stay hard brother is amazing Wow
and I get on my [ __ ] hands start
sweating I'm not a [ __ ] I'm gonna run
[Applause]